[Música]
vamos ahora hablar de revista de prensa
en directo américa de france 24 conmigo
en el estudio esta rosa pérez más de un
rosa ya félix lunes iniciamos una nueva
semana del programa y abrimos revista de
prensa con un ejercicio que ya hemos
venido haciendo recurrentemente desde
que inició esta invasiones de rusia a
ucrania ver como informe entonces la
prensa rusa toda esta guerra y para
comprender cómo llega a la población
rusa cada vez que tiene menos
alternativas de información rosa buenos
días raúl exactamente no repetimos este
ejercicio porque bueno consideramos que
es interesante como documentadas ver
como la población civil rusa puede
acceder a la información sobre lo que
sucede en ucrania y empezamos por el
medio rt que básicamente como otros
medios rusos reproduce la versión
oficial del kremlin y en concreto
respecto a la situación de mariupol
señala que rusia es decir el gobierno
ruso acusa a los nacionalistas
ucranianos de la catástrofe humanitaria
humanitaria en mariupol y un poco en la
tesis es que los radicales los
ultranacionalistas han pues ejercido una
política una campaña en todos los
territorios que controlan concretamente
pues se centra en los barrios de
mariupol y les atribuye ya sea
directamente o por provocación distintos
crímenes no que se han venido comentando
aquí en la prensa alrededor del mundo
como pues los ataques en escuelas en el
hospital maternal en el teatro de
mariupol recientemente pues o en muchos
otros por otro lado la agencia tass
también siguiendo un poco la misma línea
señala que los neonazis estarían pues
actuando un poco por libre después de
haber sido abandonados por kiev y señala
que consta porque tiene constancia de
este de esta ruptura de las relaciones a
través de información muy fiable de
inteligencia rusa y señala también pues
que la rendición hubiera sido la forma
más fácil pues de acabar con el
sufrimiento de la población al civiles
mariupol y por otro lado el con sólo
busca ya pravda por una información
exclusiva de su corresponsal en ucrania
alexandr coach señala la gente mayor
está siendo abandonado en abandonada en
las cercanías de kiev por sus hijos y
están salvados por las fuerzas
especiales rusas y que la población pues
alrededor de la capital ucraniana
estaría dando las gracias a las tropas
rusas y también concluye la operación
avanza lenta pero metódicamente y señala
que tarde o temprano kiev tendrá que
enfrentarse a una decisión y es morir
inevitablemente o ceder y llegar a un
acuerdo con rusia ahora a rózsa también
nos comentaba una actualización del caso
de la periodista del canal 1 de noticias
lo vemos con el medio ruso también
nóvaya gazeta así es porque este medio
señala que por primera vez el director
de la cadena canal 1 donde como decías
protestó la productora marina oceánico
va en contra de la invasión rusa de
ucrania se ha pronunciado no sobre este
hecho y lo ha considerado como una
traición tanto a su país como a los
compañeros de trabajo con los que
ofician y cova había trabajado durante
20 años pero lo que destaca en nóvaya
gazeta es que al hacer este comunicado
que el director de la cadena hizo a
través del canal de tele gran no pues
del propio medio y uno volvió a mostrar
las imágenes de la protesta y señala
esto como curioso y no entra en digamos
valorar cuál fue la intención del
director de la cadena señalar raúl una
cosa en éste grafismo hemos sido
nosotros los que hemos unido esta foto a
este artículo no se corresponde
realmente el titular de nóvaya gazeta
con esta imagen es un artículo que va
sin imágenes nosotros simplemente lo
hemos puesto aquí para recordar a la
audiencia pues este momento que dio la
vuelta alrededor del mundo pero nóvaya
gazeta cuando ha comentado no está
protesta lo ha hecho siempre censurando
el cartel de marina oceánico va pues
para un poco evitar no represarías por
parte del kremlin de toda esta ley que
pues se persigue las noticias falsas
contra las fuerzas armadas o llamar
guerra o invasión a lo que el crimen
considera operación especial militar
vamos ahora a comprender uno de los
focos de esta guerra como puede
redefinir todo esto el tablero
geopolítico el papel de china rosa
exacto no este es uno de los puntos que
se comentan pues desde que inició esta
invasión rusa de ucrania y sami nair en
el país dice que quizás esta invasión no
cese hasta que se logre un acuerdo entre
grandes potencias sobre la arquitectura
de la seguridad europea dice no se puede
entender esta guerra basándose solamente
la personalidad de putin sino que esto
se enmarca en la reorientación
estrategia estratégica rusa en todo tal
sintonía con china por otro lado el the
gardian también comenta que si bien este
papel de china en la guerra rusa en
ucrania pues es muy comentado a nivel
internacional y muy analizado pues esta
discusión está siendo muy censurada en
el interior del país raúl y por último
el 'global times' asegura que eeuu está
intentando jugar un doble juego pues por
un lado intentando difamar a china a
nivel internacional y por otro lado dar
intentando dañar las relaciones entre
china y rúsia y así intentando matar dos
pájaros de un tiro' que se dice
a la presión de una guerra de doble
frente rosas hagamos una consecuencia
precisamente estas sanciones económicas
tras la salida de mcdonald's de rusia
exactamente no en raúl y es que este
artículo del washington post señala algo
que se ha comentado bastante en redes
sociales y es que si bien mcdonald's
acceso las operaciones en rusia a raíz
de esta invasión al de ucrania ha
surgido una alternativa local que se
dice tío vania en referencia a una obra
de teatro de chéjov del escritor ruso
aquí vemos pues bueno ha creado cortada
la foto pero venía veíamos el logo de
mcdonald's al que se le ha dado un giro
de 90 grados lo podemos ver en un trino
que hemos también ha graficado y que lo
tenemos aquí mismo se ha dado un giro al
logo para tener esta vez del alfabeto
cirílico de tío vania y está pues
digamos reorientación esta readaptación
de los mcdonald's rusos responde a que
el kremlin ha dado permiso para no
digamos
mantener las patentes de empresas que
sean de países hostiles con una rusia y
por eso se ha permitido reapropiarse de
estas cadenas para mantener puestos de
trabajo y mantener a la baja los precios
y intentar un poco pues esquivar estas
sanciones raúl vamos a ver cómo acaba no
todo esto la norma cava no es una
empresa privada y puesto tiene que ver
cuando vuelve efectivamente y pues sólo
para terminar el 'washington post' raúl
también en este artículo pues destaca un
vídeo de cuando se abrió el primer
mcdonald's precisamente en moscú en ese
momento en la unión soviética el 31 de
enero de 1990 y asegura este medio que
esos simbolizó el triunfo de occidente
sobre sobre el comunismo al final de la
guerra fría rosa gracias por toda esa
revista de prensa vamos a saludar a
nuestra primera invitada al día
precisamente a hablar de alimentos